we have uh we have an extra human in
studio this is fantastic
extra human beings in studio uh joining
us from the worldwide leader in sports
one of the best analysts in the business
talking college and
talking round ball good to see you jay
billis hello i've been elevated to human
that is a good day for me
elevated to humans you're an actual
human and i do have to say
you know um you you have made a choice
and this is a choice that we all make
whenever we play golf
uh which it does appear you will be
doing uh as soon as you leave here today
uh you went lime green on the top is
that what like when lime green
on on for for a shirt that's yeah that's
the only one that was clean
i said i've been on vacation for a while
we also noticed on your instagram that
you've been playing a lot of golf as
well which is fantastic i haven't played
in about two weeks though oh
my god so it's a that's the longest
period of time well you've been busy we
saw what you were doing last week and
let's jump into
uh a little bit of that before we get to
the name image likeness whatever
because i don't know if you're aware uh
you being in studio for hour number two
i plan to solve
all of the problems involving college
athletics by the time you leave here
right it won't be hard don't you think
no we can do it in one word one regulate
deregulate it's over so how about that
let's start right there
deregulate it that's it simple and it's
cause today is the last
day on planet earth
in the united states of america in
college athletics where name
image and likeness laws will not be on
the books and kids will not be
we'll will be if you will not allowed
to make money off of their name image
and likeless likeness correct today's
the last day
basically yeah so today's the last day
that
amateurism has at least a shadow meaning
in our culture because the ncaa has said
for
over 100 years that college sports are
pure
amateur and that players cannot receive
any remuneration for their
athletic reputation or for play and
nil has been part of that sort of
commercials nio means name images like
this as you mentioned and that means
you know being in commercials doing an
ad things like that
uh putting your name on a camp uh
teaching teaching the sport uh that you
you
uh participate in to young people uh you
know
giving tennis lessons if you're a tennis
player right and using your name
associated with it
um now so that was
deemed to be professional so now the the
ncaa has given up on that
and now they're saying our players are
professional now we're still not going
to pay them
now they've made the distinction that
the players cannot be employees of the
university
so they they've moved the goal post to
use a you know another sports metaphor
right but
they've moved the goal post there but
but amateurism is dead basically
it's and and so um
[Music]
tomorrow how many states have i don't
know
so like six i i think i read it was at
least here in california yeah
florida right and and once you once you
include florida i mean certainly in
college athletics certainly in college
football i mean that's all she wrote i
mean the dominoes are going to have to
fall here
well it's it's all she wrote i mean
california started all this
right when senator nancy skinner put
legislation forward called the fair
pay to play act uh that's what started
and it shows you what competition looks
like in america
as soon as other states saw that
california was doing it they're like
well we have to keep up and it shows
what athletes are worth
that this is all being done because
everybody's worried about
access to players that that this is
going to this going to give a recruiting
advantage to one state or another
so what the ncaa is doing now because
they got their tails handed to him in
the supreme court
uh over the alston case where they were
again found to be a
anti-trust violator a serial antitrust
violator
now the ncaa is afraid to have any
restrictions on athletes with regard to
name image and likeness at all so
they're saying
right now starting tomorrow you can any
school can do whatever your state allows
or you can fashion your own nil policy
if your state doesn't spell it out for
you and so they
they've basically punched it down yeah
yeah well they they're
totally unprepared they didn't expect to
lose at the supreme court level
um but they've they've had their heads
in the sand for a long time on this this
was coming
and they haven't passed anything they
haven't done anything they wanted to
wait
a lot of them wanted to wait until the
outcome of the supreme court case
and and i don't think they expected to
get it handed to him
here on the rich eisen show especially
with brett kavanaugh
chiming in with his own two cents
essentially saying hey um
everybody who wants to bring more
litigation
to show off the anti-trust violations
that the ncaa
appears to be perpetrating on a mass
level
bring it because you know it looks like
they they are anti-trust violators on a
mass level
and players could get paid legitimately
paid
yeah that's where we're headed so if you
if you went back a little bit not to
bore you with
sort of some of this illegal stuff but
all this stems back to 1984
when there was a case called the board
of regents case the oklahoma and georgia
border region
so that was the last time the ncaa was
in front of the united states supreme
court but that was a case that was
brought by schools against the ncaa
saying you can't tell us how many times
we can be on television
the ncaa used to tell schools you can
only be on television so often
because they're worried it was going to
affect they'd over saturate the tv
market
and it'd affect gate receipts like
people stopped coming to the games
that the infinite wisdom of the ncaa the
television money was a pittance compared
to
ticket sales so they sued uh on
under the same theory that the players
just did and i trust and won
now in that case was some language that
is referred to as dicta like offhand
comments by the court that had nothing
to do with the ruling
that said that the thing that separates
the ncaa from the pros
is the players cannot be paid and that's
been used by
courts all those years to really
for the ncaa to win their cases on the
amateurism front
uh and and so the courts gave great
deference to the ncaa they probably won
75 percent of their cases in court
the alston case that just got decided
took all that away
like the court said nope this doesn't
matter anymore
it was wrong at the time you it was used
as dicta it shouldn't have been
it was used essentially as law and it
shouldn't have been
and no longer and from now on ncaa
you are going to have to justify your
business practices in every case
and show that your policies are not
anti-competitive
and make a pro-competitive justification
for it and kavanaugh said
in a concurring opinion that um
the ncaa's the way the ncaa does
business with regard to athletes would
be illegal in
any other industry like if they tried to
do that to restaurant workers and said
you know all restaurant workers have to
work for the love of the love of the
the food yeah the love of food um that'd
be illegal
i mean he did he he went down a list of
like medical workers if they did it just
for for
for medicine you know for the good of
the public good be illegal
uh if you did it in law it'd be for love
of the law it'd
be illegal and and the last line in
there was the ncaa is not above the law
and if if people think that courts
around the country
are not going to take that as this is
what we have to do now
like the the the deference that the ncaa
got is over
and and not not just on on sort of
academic benefits which the alston case
was about
but name image and likeness and actual
pay
i don't think the ncaa is going to be
able to win these cases going forward
so uh j bill is here on the rich eisen
show
maybe a law can be written to save them
because that's i'm already
reading that mitch mcconnell's come out
and said maybe we need to pass a law
to you know assist the ncaa i'm kind of
putting i don't know if you use the word
assist but maybe we need a law here to
address
what's going on in the ncaa are they
like lobbying congress to basically say
come in here and
let's write a law where we don't have to
pay players and run that up the supreme
court flag policy
well the supreme court wouldn't have
anything to do with that if if congress
passes a law that's that's
going to carry the day that's really
what the court says like if congress
wants to step in and take care of this
they can
right and give give the ncaa nan a trust
exemption and allow them to continue to
violate that's
where they would go right that's where
they're going so the ncaa will ask for
an anti-trust exemption i cannot
imagine that congress as divided as it
is
would give a serial anti-trust violator
an anti-trust exemption
when they're making billions of dollars
and say okay but you can keep
restricting this one aspect of the
business here which which
clearly it's being proven now is is
very valuable to you and very valuable
in the open market in the free market
so i would have a hard time imagining
that's going to happen
but there is a thought process out there
right now that without
a national standard you know people use
the term wild wild west
which i just call business uh they also
say bidding wars they're going to be
bidding wars for players
that's called business you know the rest
of the world that's called business if
somebody
if one entity offers you a contract and
another entity says no we'll see that
and raise it and they go back and forth
or you're buying a house
and you bid on it that's called business
um so we can handle this it's not that
big of a deal
the one thing which i'm hopeful of and i
believe will happen
is from july 1 forward
when we don't have federal legislation
people are going to find that the world
will not spin off its axis
uh the games will go off on time
everybody their checks are going to
clear
everything's going to be okay and
doomsday isn't around the corner
in college sports uh it's not a big deal
like the the just like we've had we've
had drastic change since 1984 since that
last
supreme court case the board of regents
case we've had drastic change but it's
all been on the revenue side
so there's been there's been incredible
increases in revenue generated
and then in in salaries paid in
facilities built
and nobody had a problem with it nobody
said put the brakes on this stop this we
got to go to congress
to stop this nobody said that well i
think people
have no problem if institutions
um are uh
paying for new buildings and for coaches
they don't have a problem with that they
would have a problem with a bidding war
for an athlete's services because there
will only be a handful of
institutions who can afford that or
you know i'll put it it won't be the
battle for the hearts and minds of the
student athlete to see if they can come
to their program
it'll be who's got better buddy
guarantees to pony up the cash
for these people and that's where i
think people
will say hey the world is spinning off
its axis and there's really only five
teams that can win a national
championship because they've got the
money for the athlete
which is already happening because
instead of instead of
the the booster giving money to
uh provide to a player via contract
they're giving it to the school to build
these gigantic facilities or to get the
coach fired or hired or all these
different things
the facilities that are being built now
are being built for one reason and one
reason only and that's for recruiting
so rather because we cannot offer
anything to the players what we're
saying is
look at the fabulous environment we'll
build for you
so you can come in here and and you'll
be able to sit and plush leather seats
and
while you watch film and you'll eat this
way or that way and actually eating is a
good example
of of sort of the world spinning off its
axis theory that the ncaa has had
so you'll probably remember this it
might be might have been five six years
ago
uh the ncaa used to control what players
ate
so you could have one meal a day
provided by your
your university and and it got to the
point where
where like if michigan would have a
morning workout
uh they might want something for the
players to eat there in the locker room
so you they had a rule it was the fruits
nuts and bagels rule
so you could provide fruit nuts and
bagels
but you couldn't provide you couldn't
have cream cheese on the bagel because
that would make it a meal
so you could have grapes but not grape
jelly you could have peanuts but not
peanut butter stuff like that
so we used to make fun of that all the
time guys like me
about how ridiculous that is that we're
policing
a spread on a bank and so i actually had
this discussion with someone at the ncaa
one time and
and there's a wonderful woman who works
there that said
so it's okay with you if a school
feeds their players steak and lobster
every meal
and i i didn't know how to respond
without starkey but i said i don't think
they're going to do that but yeah it is
okay with me
i i i don't have a problem with that and
so now
uh when people are saying that's an
incredible advantage that east carolina
cannot afford to provide its players the
same thing as north carolina
you're going i just don't want to live
in a world where everyone has to be
malnourished because east carolina can't
afford it
like that doesn't make any sense and so
now
you go into these facilities whether
it's alabama michigan duke north
carolina
they have these wonderful eating
facilities for the athletes
and they're competing on that level now
look what we can
feed you you know we can fuel you
properly you know the
nutrition stations all that's it's great
like what what's the harm
if if a school wants to do that great
and to your point
on the economics there are a lot of
places can't afford to do that
too bad like if you can't afford to do
it maybe you shouldn't be in this
business
and and like we don't have rules in the
hamburger industry saying
mcdonald's can do more for their
employees
than the local mom and pop shop can so
everybody has to get paid less
the world doesn't work that way so then
last question on this we'll take a break
come back
and um you know i'll try and delve into
what name image and like this will look
like and we're already getting a sense
of that already
um you were also at the nba combine in
chicago i want to hit you on that and
some of the other aspects j bill is here
for the rest of the hour but my last
question for you here is
what would be you know how much would a
quarterback
at the sec make you know how much would
the quarterback at alabama
make is it possible that somebody would
make more money being the quarterback at
alabama than being the star
wide out for the jacksonville jaguars
you know like is it entirely possible
to see that one day it could be entirely
possible but to me
that's the free market that's what the
players are worth and i don't have any
problem with it
you know we don't ask not that you're
not asking but we don't ask
like what did natalie portman make while
she was in college
because she did movies and there there
are a bunch of
musicians out there that are on music
scholarships
and they're not told what they can earn
or accept while they're in school and
have it affect their status
to me the only thing the ncaa needs to
do is the only thing they need to police
on the eligibility front is
is is the athlete a full-time student
enrolled in good standing that's it the
rest of it
is up to the individual school now if an
individual school doesn't want to
pay an athlete then don't if they don't
want to allow their athletes to take
advantage of
nil then tell them if you're here we
don't allow that
that's fine just like byu doesn't allow
their students to
drink caffeine like go ahead but
there will be other other entities in
the marketplace that will allow them to
do that and maybe
maybe more athletes will start going to
these other places
what about the idea that another school
can come in after
one year at alabama and say i'll pay you
more for your sophomore year
what do you think is that is that a
something that like free agency
or well we already have a letter a
letter i know there's a transfer portal
if you will and there's time or what
have you but that's based off of well
you just lost your playing time there
you need playing time you can come here
or
or who knows but what if it's a money
thing like i you know
you said no to us your freshman year but
hey we saw what you did sophomore year
you can hit it
more than what you're going to be paid
in your second year of your letter of
intent
and but is it it'll probably be via
contract so
the schools right now the way nil is
supposed to work the schools aren't
going to be able to participate in
providing
the players deals but ultimately that's
what's going to happen
damn um because you know you're
there's too much money out there for the
schools so the university
in the future the university mark and
the player are going to be
used together because those revenue
streams are just too valuable
and the universities will see that and
they'll they'll go that direction but
right now that that would be prohibited
but if you were to say hey to to hey
rich eyes and quarterback at michigan
hey the quarterback at ohio state right
now is making twice what you're making
if you transfer to ohio state
pretty sure you're going to get that too
yeah that could that could be a powerful
uh draw but you know right now we're not
we're not restricting athletes or we're
not restricting
any other you know spending control or
business uh issue in college sports it's
just the athlete
i don't have a problem with it and
that's why i think pay the players
because if you sign them to a contract
they're not going to be going anywhere
um that that's that's where ultimately i
think this should go
and people say well you know what are we
going to pay them how do we know
all these universities have 30 000
employees they don't stay up at night
going do we pay the landscape
professional the same as the head coach
i don't know how to do this
but there's so much turnover in
athletics like there's no turnover with
their employees
there's all kind of turnover they have
300 athletes they can figure it out it's
not that big of a deal
let's get into what name image and
likeness can look like graham mertz
the quarterback of the wisconsin badges
did you see what he did no
okay he has come up with a logo
there it is on the screen that's his
logo
and he trademarked it and i imagine
he'll put it on
apparel or what have you it looks very
tiger woods like to be honest with you
cool you know but that's it that's the g
and the m and he's ready to he is ready
to come out of the
nil box tomorrow
and they should and the player should i
mean do i think that
that all these players are going to be
able to sell their own apparel lines no
but they should be able to participate
in commerce just like everyone else and
and it's amazing how a lot of people are
freaking out over this
that oh my you know like the floodgates
are opening to the you know the gates of
hell here
and i had somebody text me this morning
about it saying now
so you're telling me if a player um
starts a
a company an llc to sell t-shirts
that boosters could buy an equity stake
in that company
yeah if they wanted to unless the school
or the conference prohibits it
uh yeah they could you know do you
really think that's
you know the the apocalypse being upon
us i don't i don't think it's that big
of a deal
what if it's in a state where the again
this is where we're relying on your
law degree where i think you know and
i'm definitely gonna
uh screw this up i think you once
attempted to put barney behind bars if
i'm not mistaken
that would have been a good result i
think for everyone right so
um but what happens if a
you know a state like california florida
says go ahead make your
make your money off your name image and
likeness and then a school says no you
cannot have a booster put that money
in your llc that is legal under the nil
that's something we won't allow you to
do will this wind up in like a state
supreme court and then wind up in front
of the u.s supreme court
it could i mean if if the if the
the state allows it then i can't imagine
the university trying to
prohibit it but that that's sort of
what i believe this should be in in the
grand scheme of things is that
individual entities individual schools
should be able to make their own
decisions on how they want to handle
their programs and their
their employees and their workers and
the supreme court made it pretty clear
that athletes are working they consider
athletes to be workers
uh but if if uh if a school doesn't want
to pay a player then don't pay a player
if you don't really you don't even have
to give a player scholarship
so while while we're you know not to
totally avoid your question but while
we're worried about
uh sort of fairness across the board is
this going to be fair to this player
versus that player you know what about
the offensive lineman when the
quarterback's going to be the most
valuable
we don't ask that question with regard
to playing time you know the coaches
don't say well you know we need to play
everybody the same amount of minutes
it's only fair they're all working just
as hard and
and our sid needs to be mindful that we
can't have the media just going to the
quarterback after the game they've got
to ask questions of everybody we've got
to make everybody available i have no
problem
with this nil stuff at all jay it can be
totally incumbent upon the quarterback
to tell i always use the name buddy
garrity because i you know it's a pop
culture phrase that people understand as
a booster and a guy who's
like owns a car place and in whatever
you know
town you could easily tell buddy garrity
you want to hire me
to pitch your cars you gotta get my
lineman too
yeah you gotta pay my alignment it's
like you know most favored nations
you pay me to get me you gotta get my
linemen taken care of too
period end of story and i have no
problem with that i have no problem with
this player
you know uh going ahead and saying you
know
you i'm worth this much i'm the star
player here
any of the the women that we just saw
crush it
on the worldwide leader in sports
playing softball
where the whole the country was locked
in
on that why shouldn't they get their
money because they just hit a great home
run or a terrific play
ever i have no problem with that but the
funny part about this discussion with me
rich
is you know so we're talking about how
much an athlete might be worth and we're
using
you know the abstract because they
haven't been allowed anything so we we
always started zero
that most of them aren't even worth the
scholarship well yeah actually that's
the least amount they're worth
because that's what they're allowed
that's that's the only thing they're
allowed
um but if you start looking at the the
employees
uh of of the athletic department the
paid employees right now whether they're
assistant coaches
or director of basketball operations or
the analytics guys or what whatever you
name the employee
so they're worth 600 000
plus benefits really but not the
athletes
like the offensive lineman's worth worth
barely a scholarship
according to some people but the
director of operations
is worth 250 000 or the strength coach
is worth
a million like come on man the players
are worth a ton
and the fact that we're worried so
deathly afraid
that they're going to be these quote
unquote bidding wars shows you how
valuable they are
and they ought to be able to realize
upon that value
and if we have reasonable business
restrictions
to deal with i'm cool with that let's
talk about it
but we the players start at zero like i
look at it almost like a faucet
so for the rest of the world the the
business faucet
is turned on completely with an athlete
college athlete we're talking about
well how many drips are we gonna allow
the athlete let's start with zero and
then we'll start talking about how many
drips and maybe we open it a little bit
and to me that's not the way it goes we
let's deregulate this completely
and amateurism's dead allow the athletes
like
that their only worry should be is this
legal
uh am i paying my taxes am i doing you
know are you doing all the things
because we don't worry about the stuff
when we snarkily told them when they
were quote-unquote amateurs when we told
them
hey you want money go get a freaking job
nobody worried about their tax
consequences when we told them that
right or whether they could show up on
time for work or whether their job would
affect their
their football or their basketball or
all that stuff or academics or their
academics nobody cared about that we say
you want money get a damn job like the
rest of us
well they're now they have a job like
the rest of us
uh and they're being treated like the
rest of us at least on the nil front
last question for you on this jay uh i'm
sure you've been asked this before i
might have asked you like would you be
interested in running the ncaa like if
if amer was out
if somebody's just like said hey this
last go-round with the ncaa we're
getting our ass kicked in front of
congress we're getting right
let's go in a totally different
direction that this this is
now obvious where things are going they
see you on tv
you've got an outstanding background and
the law
as well as knowing the the business and
college athletics would you be
interested in i have always said that i
will do
whatever i can to help so if i felt like
it was helpful
and there would be some authority behind
it to where you could
actually do what you felt was
appropriate then of course i would
i that that will never happen why
because my
views even though a lot of this stuff i
feel like i've been proven right of late
well i mean the canary and the coal mine
is dead
yeah i mean and buried
mark emmert and don remy his his second
hand who's now
going into the biden administration they
stomped that canary to death
the truth is rich this didn't have to
happen the supreme court decided the
alston case because the ncaa appealed it
to the supreme court
and and they did so after having a
favorable ruling in the ninth circuit
like the ninth circuit kept amateurism
alive
and didn't touch the the good stuff out
of the board of regents case yeah they
spiked their own football
on themselves it's like they couldn't
handle somebody telling them
okay you can't do this one little part
you can do the rest right you can't do
this one little part and they freaked
out
i know which is why if i'm a school
president or i'm a school anybody i
would say what the hell are we doing
like get this guy out
let's get somebody and we see which way
the wind is blowing like i said the
canary and the coal mine dropped that a
very long time ago
that's why i mean you said you don't i
wouldn't i would if i'd help i don't
think they would ever do that because it
would
it would be capitulating you know and
sort of giving up
on all the things they've argued for all
these years like that it's got to be
difficult like i do
i have so many friends within the
structure right
ads presidents um even people in
indianapolis that work in the ncaa
office
most of them are the overwhelming
majority are great people
they've been hamstrung by bad policy
but but i do feel for them that that
they've
they've ridden this horse for so long
and now the horse is dead they wrote it
into the ground
and and their whole way of thinking is
going to have to change
now i think it's going to be easy for it
to change because they're going to see
that it's not that big of a deal there's
a lot of money to be made not just for
the athletes the universities are going
to make a lot of money off of nil
if they allow the athletes to use
university marks
in tandem like if they can work together
uh
athlete image and likeness along with
the university mark just like we do in
the nfl the nba all that stuff
there's a ton of money to be made a ton
of revenue for the universities but they
look at it right now they look at it
as a zero-sum game that every dollar an
athlete makes is a dollar that's taken
out of the university account
you know that that if if a a car dealer
to your example if a car dealer's given
a
a contract to a player well normally
they would have given that money to the
school
and so the school's looking at that
we're losing money by athletes making
money i don't see it that way and i
think they're going to find out it's not
going to work that way in the long run
j bill is here in studio uh on the rich
eisen show um
what goes on at an nba combine what does
it
i i i missed it i'll be very honest with
you i know what it goes on in an nfl
combine
or is there just a lot of chit chat
horse trading similar a lot of
rumors there's some similarities to it
right um you know they do the
the anthro stuff so they all do um you
know the vertical leap and they do the
shuttles they run and all that stuff the
three-quarter court sprint
so they get all their time and they get
measured with their wingspans which
makes me very happy
uh and then they uh but then they play
so
the the top prospects after getting
measured and getting and they do
interviews just like the nfl coming up
um the uh but then they play they play
five on five okay so we actually see
what they do
yeah but the the the best players don't
play the
the expected top draft picks don't play
the quarterbacks don't throw at the
combo yeah that's been that way forever
and why would you why would you give him
an extra peak when you don't have to
uh then you know we go to this thing
where we're at the level now and have
been for a while
guy plays well on day one doesn't play
on day two
you know his agent tells him to shut it
down and
that's fine i mean you don't have to
play but because the players right
now before they're drafted they're not
members of the nba players association
they're not required to do anything
right
says yeah right and uh so you know maybe
in the future that's something they'll
look at
because the the nba combine now the nba
draft combine has become
uh there's a it's a public event now the
tv
tv covers it and oh yeah you know i
played in the
uh so in 1986 i went to the
it was called the nba pre-draft camp yes
in chicago moody bible institute i think
you know dennis rodman played in scott
skyles
uh all that stuff and you know i was one
of the idiots that played it yeah
and like look look at some of those
names there were some pretty good
players that played in my mind
i mean that's i'm not gonna lie
really attractive i would agree look at
the hair um nate mcmillan was on your
team
mcmillan was on my team and uh but it
was it was an
awesome experience but there was no
coverage of that they left
they let the media in like there was
this is a pretty funny one so they let
the media in to do interviews so we're
all kind of lined up
uh against the the bleachers that have
been pushed in at this place
and i'm being interviewed by some local
media from maybe north carolina or the
southeast or something and
scott skyles is standing right next to
me getting interviewed by all the media
from michigan
he's michigan state michigan state great
player at michigan state played in the
nba for a long time coached for a long
time in the nba
so he they asked him is this the hardest
thing you've ever done
and he said i just got out of jail
because this is club med
i was like damn i'm in the wrong place i
don't know if i can handle this
well in the nfl that would be a red flag
uh you know having been to a combine
here and there so who's number one who
do you think goes to the pistons
uh i think kate cunningham from oklahoma
state will be number one
he's the most complete player you know
six eight handles it
point guard shoots it he does he does
everything plays a bliss on both ends of
the floor he's not a
freak athlete but he's very athletic
he'll do just fine but
this is probably the deepest draft that
top to bottom like one through 60 the
deepest draft that i've
covered that's good it's been my first
draft for espn was 2003
the lebron uh dwyane wade chris bosh
carmelo draft
d'arco drafted darko d'arco draft draft
um
so this is the deepest one oh my gosh
and you know the main scuttlebutt at the
people maybe chit-chatting was what if
ben simmons is a viable
philadelphia 76er anymore because that
happened just as
the combine was heading woj ted a story
about
you know um rich paul of clutch sports
meeting with philly brass and things of
that name
where do you stand on that subject
matter i mean the more they
talk about it right now the harder it is
to trade ben simmons for
value um it's that's the hardest
sort of thing that i've seen evaluating
a player is
normally when a player has a struggles
to shoot the ball in college
we say and it's accurate that that
that's going to improve
that's one area where the player can
really improve
and you know i i don't know anybody that
said well he's going to be afraid to
pull the trigger in five years
um nobody said that it's incredible and
it's
it's it's incredible it's like watching
david duvall
when he had the yips or couldn't
couldn't draw the club back and all that
stuff
it i can't figure it out um because
there have been a lot of players that
shot it poorly in college that went on
to be decent shooters
and guys you had to go out and guard ben
simmons does that
and he works hard like he he he's an
excellent defender it's not like he's
he's you know taking it easy only wants
to play on offense that kind of stuff
um but but it's clearly a mental problem
a mental issue for him and one that he
needs to get over because he's an
all-star
without being able to shoot it if he
could shoot it a little bit you know he
he'd be
he'd be up there in the the very top
echelon yeah i mean regressing is
definitely the word so
in the nfl we always say it takes five
years to see whether
somebody is you know nfl
worthy or not see if a draft can pan out
team wise
obviously other individual players like
you know patrick mahomes you can kind of
get the drift
what about the nba i mean is it possible
that we're still can evaluate ben
simmons at this point in time of his
career
yeah i mean he can still continue to get
better i mean i was joking with a couple
of friends of mine that
you know right now we're talking about
some different players that
uh one of them was chris duarte from
oregon
and saying well he's 23 years old like
like he's ancient and
he'll be retiring after his rookie year
or something
when that was the age of a lot of guys
when they came into the league
15 years ago um that that everybody was
a senior
and you talked about them being a rookie
that had a lot to learn
you know now it's it seems like these
younger guys have an advantage because
they haven't established who they are
yet
and they've got a lot of room for growth
so
sometimes you're hearing about a guy he
you know he's only 18.
well okay but how good is he and do you
really think he can get that much better
uh but some of these players like i
can't i would love to see
if the nfl took the restrictions off
of when they can when they can declare
and go into the draft
i think the nfl would be just like the
nba they'd be drafting
sophomores and and they would have
drafted trevor lawrence after his
freshman right
that is you know and i've talked to a
lot of evaluators about this and you
know
people would say the this is just
covering for
uh you know using college as a
a free minor league system for them but
the difference between the nba
and and the nfl is some of these kids
will get their heads torn off
like some grown ass man 30 year old 32
year old coming for
for a 19 year old or 20 year old it
would be particularly
physically devastating it could be for
those kids but there are some outliers
like you would say trevor lawrence or
leonard fournette that one year we had
to go back to lsu you know after having
that spiritual would have been okay
yeah there are some that would
definitely have been okay but on the
whole most of them would get their asses
handed
but one but one of the one of the
reasons we're able to say that
is because we don't have we don't know
we don't have any data
that's because they're not allowed and
you know like i i think it would be very
much the same i think you'd have a
number of players that would be able to
go in and compete and make rosters and
all that stuff but
but just on the talent side they would
want them as early as they could get
them
because they wouldn't want they wouldn't
want to wait and risk not being able to
take trevor lawrence when he was a
freshman or something like that right
you know the reason that happened like
you know college football is
50 years older than the nfl right and
was established
and the ncaa put a rule in i don't even
know how many years ago was 75
80 years a rule where if you worked in
any capacity in the professional leagues
you couldn't know
you could you were ineligible to work in
college so if you coached in the nfl
whatever you couldn't come back and ever
work in college
and the nfl actually went to the ncaa on
bended knee and said please don't do
this you'll kill us before we get off
the ground
right and they they guaranteed them we
will not touch your players
until they graduate we won't draft them
until they graduate that was the way
that worked you know when that changed
like they didn't start the nfl didn't
start drafting juniors because they
thought
well players have advanced now now
they're ready and they won't get their
ass handed to him right they did it
because the usfl started drafting
juniors
that makes sense 1984. and now we have
nick saban yeah yeah
exactly exactly all right i saw you even
instagram this out because i follow you
on instagram as well
uh you instagrammed out your appearance
on the white shadow
how did you wind up on the white shadow
back in the day one of my high school
teammates
matt baker his dad dick baker was the
head coach at loyola marymount at one
point
and and has been an nba scout for a
million years so back in
that time during the 70s he was in
hollywood as a an ex
he did a lot of work as an extra every
movie back in the 70s that had
basketball in it yes
dick baker was like the official uh the
referee
and like one-on-one like robbie benson
yeah i don't know if it's one-on-one
the fish that saves just about i mean
you name it i mean he's in the six
million dollar man all these different
things
so he was a technical consultant for the
white shadow okay so
in 1978 79 probably
um he got our team on the show as the
opposing
team of carver high and
the plot of the the particular show was
one of the carver players was
transferring to essentially this
all-white high school
and he was leaving carver and
transferred to our school
and uh and so we were the players on the
opposing team we were all 16
17 years old and had no idea that all of
the actors that played the carver high
players were in their 30s
so we were talking to these guys you
know the the director would yell cut
and then we'd start talking to them you
know like like
they went to a crosstown high school
we're like hey my mom's picking me up
after this you know how are you getting
home
you guys lighting up a cigarette get
away from me kid
did you meet ken howard that day did you
meet him yeah i met him and uh
and you know salami and all these all
those guys
coolidge uh they were great um
aside from coolidge though none of them
could play dead
like they were no no they were actors so
none of them could play
and so they used to do these dolly shots
where the the gym they played in was
on a soundstage so there was you know it
was it was
made up i mean it's tiny yeah and in
order to dunk they would have to jump
except for coolidge they would have to
jump off a ramp um
a lot of a lot of cuts to a shot going
through the basket that they didn't
necessarily make
um it was pretty funny a lot in a way
as a 17 year old kid very disappointing
look at that number
three in your program number one in your
heart
look at the oak ridge forward right
there now you you were being
berated because you were laughing during
the uh the coach
tearing your team a new one that was the
opening of the show
so so we're coming into the locker room
we we've just been beaten i think
and uh and the coach is supposed to yell
at me yes
and so uh they had they had inserted our
high school into so essentially
our high school name had just beaten oak
ridge
and so he's yelling at another player
and i started laughing and then he
turned it on me
and uh and so it wound up being like i
it was foreshadowing for playing for
coach k
because that was basically every
post-game speech for the remainder of my
career
so you never laughed at a coach k during
the middle of a coach k
uh not screaming i waited till he left
the room and then we started laughing
jay williams told about a time where
where where coach k's hip went out
during uh
during a speech or something like that
and he was down on the floor
he's had a few of those where where said
that you know like
one time uh when i was a grad assistant
he wanted to show the team that they
weren't going after loose balls
like they needed to so he threw a ball
in front of in front of the team
in the locker room and then dove on it
and wriggled around and
you know growled and this is what you do
and then when he went back into the
coach's locker room he dropped down on
his knees and he's like oh you know
because he was you know he was 50 some
years old if i did that now i'd be
injured saying the same thing and uh and
so you know a couple times i'd get away
for
the the thing i laughed at most with
coach k and he
is he's the best coach and the best guy
of course
but he had a thing once when i was a
player where he he gave us the what for
about we need to have attention to
detail like no detail is too small
and we have to be able to tell each
other tough things we have to be tough
enough where we hold each other
accountable
and if somebody makes a mistake we we
correct it and
and the guy doesn't get upset about it
he takes the correction all
you know accountability and and uh
you know and attention to detail so then
he goes and then he says
and now the specifically these three
things we have to clean up
and number one on the list was rebound
and he spelled it
r-e-b-o-u-b
so billy king who later on was the uh
president of the 76ers
and that's leaned over to me and says do
you think he wants us to point that out
like like attention to detail like he's
testing us
yeah you do it
[Laughter]
so we didn't say anything right the rest
of practice
every time a shot went up we'd go rebub
and he caught on he goes oh yeah that's
real funny
very good real funny uh he didn't care
for that one
rebound rebound duke is not a good
rebounding team
that might come out this year in his
final year duke is not a good rebounding
team
if they could only rebound the better
but i love that billy thought like that
might be like a
four-dimensional chess way of coach k
trying to see if you're paying attention
we were afraid of disappointing him that
not only
not only that we would get the carver
high treatment or the oak ridge coach
treatment but that that we you know we
didn't want to disappoint him
and so if he asked us to do something we
wanted to do it uh
but but we were thinking that way that
is this a test this is
okay what do we do here do we need to do
this jay billis everybody follow him on
twitter
and instagram uh at jaybilis on twitter
and at real deal
it changed to at jay bilassan i was able
to get the real deal out there
very cause so many people grab that name
can you imagine all the people it is
your name
imagine like this we're back here on
peacock in a second hour three coming up
we're still here on tv that's the way
things work around here so before there
was
nil there was f n b
fruits nuts and and bagels
so there was fnb before nil yeah come a
long way from fnb
come a long way that you couldn't have
you couldn't have a spread on your bagel
otherwise it was a meal and counted
against which
which school was serving bagels like all
of them all of them yeah
you that's all you could give to the
players like before a morning workout or
something like that
bagels yeah the player that's like it
was so stupid because
you'd have to call a smear
we would call compliance and say can we
give the players cereal
nope can't do it come on that was
that was the way it worked and some
schools used to like i used to hear from
coaches about this stuff all the time
uh uh some schools would would say we
have three people called the ncaa
separately
and we get three different
interpretations we just pick the one we
like
and that's how screwed up things were
this was my favorite this was
years ago to school i can't tell you the
name but okay uh school's got parking
rules so seniors get the best parking of
course
followed by juniors and the like so
junior
basketball player is rooming with senior
manager junior basketball player as a
car
senior manager doesn't senior manager
who's his roommate says
how about this i'll get a parking pass
and you can use it you just pay for it
at the end of the year
good uh they do that the junior goes
into the junior basketball player goes
to the bursar's office to pay for the
parking pass but it's on the on the the
senior manager's name
so somebody in the person's office says
well why are you doing that that's kind
of weird
so they just called somebody in
compliance compliance says well we
better check with the ncaa
they suspended the player for i don't
know how many games seven games
because they deemed the senior manager
a member of the basketball staff so that
was an impermissible benefit
and you're going wait a minute he's
living with the member of the basketball
staff
yeah like that that's so stupid i
couldn't believe it
and but that kind of thing has been
going on for a hundred plus years now
maybe with nil and the fact that the
players and maybe we'll start
will begin to stop all of this
ridiculousness
and uh there's a a tennis player from
umass
named brittany collins who
found out she's a professional tennis
player found out recently that her team
all their records were vacated
because uh they received a 250 dollar
credit uh for a phone jack on a rotary
phone in their dorm oh my gosh
and and you know that's kind of thing
that goes on impermissible benefit
jay bill is here on the rich eisen show
thanks for coming on thanks for having
me
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here